he came out and said I deserve to be
murdered who said that Elon Musk Elon
Musk said I should be murdered for what
I did oh about Sandy Hook yeah he said
he said he said you know what Alex Jones
did attacking those people when their
children died is the worst thing on
Earth not being Taliban not sex driving
and that's all fine I mean seriously he
said Alex Jones is the worst I will
never reinstate him it would be as
Christ said he should have a stone tied
around his neck and Throne of the ocean
there's another tweet where he says he
quoted Christ he said it'll be better
for him to have a millstone he he
deserves to have a millstone tied around
his neck but you have you have high
praise for Elon you just said that he's
way smarter than a trumpet right what he
did to him he's like you're right he's
Satan I won't bring him back I don't
bring everybody he just played their
game that's 3D chess I love it